so the question is what can accelerate
growth in the Middle East I think is
very important that growth gets
accelerated because there are clear
challenges one is why we are here jobs
need to be created 51 million jobs need
to be creative were the next five years
growth is needed to accelerate in order
to create these jobs they are aboard if
my opinion needs to do three things the
first one is to solve this dichotomy
between urgency and complexity the
answer now is very urgent the Arab
Spring is ongoing for mollys upcoming if
there is no reform show is urgent on one
side to find a solution but the answer
is very complex at the same time there
are many moving parts how to solve this
dichotomy between the urgency and
complexity just sketch out a plan and
change revolution into evolution so
basically requires leadership the
leaders of the other board will need to
give up some of their powers sketching
out this plan of more democratization of
the region accepting and hearing what
the region is saying and that's the
first the base without political will
nothing has with that point number two
is bet on innovation they are aboard has
been exporting ideas for centuries it's
time to go back to export ideas solar
power water treatment there are many
areas where they are aboard has a
comparative advantage and and needs and
when comparative advantage and needs are
together you can become a leader so
become a leader in technology and
innovation and then point number three
exports so once you have something the
world one
exported say Sally to Asia there is no
clearer driver of global demanded the
Asian internal demand so target is a
target now that Europe and the US are
softening a bit their growth rate but
still they are going to grow target the
world through exports of course
coordination policy coordination armaan
ization of administrative barriers trade
policy internal infrastructure is needed
and and this is very important and
probably everything should be
kick-started by heavy infrastructure
infrastructure spending in the in the
MENA region to build highways railways
and energy ways to create a more compact
region thank you very much